das ist wirklich eine super spannende
entdeckung ein niederländisches
forschungsteam hat jetzt einen achten
kontinent aufgespürt der quasi verloren
gegangen war
dieser ist wohl vor 120 millionen jahren
unter das heutige südeuropa gerutscht
sein name greater adria und der absolute
hammer verformte relikt den dieses
mysteriösen content sind übrigens heute
noch auf der erde zu finden klick zum
science-fiction-epos täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke und dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
vom weltraum aus gesehen sei die erde
keinesfalls immer so aus wie sie jetzt
aussieht vor 240 millionen jahren gab es
beispielsweise dem superkontinent pangäa
von seiner form her erinnert er ein
wenig an pacman bank erteilt die sich
dann im laufe der zeit in zwei teile
zum einen laura sia im norden daraus
gegen asien nordamerika und europa
hervor neben laura sie entstand aber
auch noch ein weiterer teil nämlich das
fragment im süden gondwana genannt
daraus formten sich südamerika
australien die antarktis und das heutige
afrika vor aus gondwana ist von rund 240
millionen jahren offensichtlich ein
weiterer fünfter kontinent entstanden
diese landmasse etwa so groß wie
grönland wanderte dann nach norden zu
großen teilen befand sich auf ihm ein
flacher tropischer ozean
diese neuen wirklich spektakulären
erkenntnisse stammen von einem
niederländischen forschungsteam die
fachleute nennen den neu aufgespürten
kontinent greater adria dieser verloren
gegangene achter kontinent ist wohl vor
120 millionen bis 100 millionen jahren
mit europa kollidiert und das bleibt
nicht ohne folgen wie fachleute jetzt
rekonstruieren konnten sediment auflagen
von greater adria wurden abgeschafft und
schoben sich zu gebirgen zusammen die
restliche landmasse drehte sich gegen
den uhrzeigersinn
ein etwa 100 kilometern dickes kontinent
stück rutschte unter das heutige
südeuropa in den erdmantel das
forschungsteam schreibt in seiner
aktuellen studien dass diese relikte
dort noch bis heute verfolgt werden
können bis in eine tiefe von achtung
1500 kilometern seismische wellen machen
das möglich doch wie bereits angedeutet
sind einige reste dieses kontinents auch
heutzutage immer noch sichtbar und zwar
in den gebirgen südosteuropas und in
teilen der alpen konkret sind
1 relikte von greater adria noch auf dem
balkan in griechenland der türkei und
den gebirgszügen das abnehmen zu finden
dazu der geologe bei wafern hinz bergen
der an den geologischen analysen
beteiligt war
vergesst atlantis ohne es zu merken
verbringen heute unzählige touristen
ihren urlaub auf dem verlorenen
kontinent von greater adria der einzig
verbliebene rest dieses kontinents ist
ein streifen der sich von turin durch
die adria bis zur ferse des
italienischen stiefels erstreckt dem
verlorenen kontinent kamen die fachleute
durch harte und langwierige arbeit auf
die spur zehn jahre lang hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
gesteinsproben die von greater adler
stammen könnten gesucht also tatsächlich
vergleichbar mit der suche nach der
nadel im heuhaufen
denn relikte des verlorenen kontinents
können in mehr als 30 ländern aufgespürt
werden
zu den herausforderungen heißt es in der
studie der mittelmeerraum ist ein
geologisches trümmerfeld alles ist
verbogen gebrochen und übereinander
gestapelt verglichen damit ist der
himalaya geradezu ein simples system
unter anderem interessierten sich die
fachleute für die magnetisierung und das
alter dieser funde um mit hilfe einer
speziellen software das schicksal des
verlorenen kontinent zu rekonstruieren
doch die arbeit hat sich gelohnt und die
geschichte von greater adria kann jetzt
zurückverfolgt werden
gibt es atlantis wirklich anklicken
anschauen und marius angeschrieben
abonnieren unbedingt supercooler kanal
bis dann bleibt dran